foreign
Paul you said it allows me to do more
with my life and that's everything I
want to hear you talk more about that in
a way that can paint a picture for
people of what the possibilities of
Health are because I do believe
convenience is a big factor but I think
in our culture food as entertainment is
another factor and when people consider
the possibility of eliminating these
toxic foods from their diet it almost
seems like well what do I have to live
for because food is really a major part
of going out enjoying life enjoying
friends and having fun what can life
look like when you eliminate the foods
by which we have previously defined fund
and fulfillment yeah that's such an
important point so I'll have to I'll
address it sequentially if you choose to
make food entertainment that's your
quality of life equation right there and
you will almost certainly sacrifice
Optimal Health and so if you choose to
make Optimal Health not such a
wishy-washy hand wavy term I should find
something better but if you really want
fullness of life then I mean in for me
it's I'm 45 years old I want to surf
when I'm 85. I'm not married you know I
want a relationship I want to have kids
kids at 45 they're going to be 15 when
I'm 60 right if I had kids this year I
want to be able to Surf with them all my
life like that's what it means for me
like I want Vitality as long as I can
get it out of life and
I remember meeting you guys I don't know
four years ago yeah and like since then
I I feel like
a lot of people or some people have
benefited from what I do and I feel a
responsibility to keep doing it I want
Clarity of mind so I can keep doing
something that I feel responsible to
keep doing because
maybe I can say something in a unique
way that that adds value to the world
and so I think that a lot of us
don't understand our potential as humans
and don't understand our physical
potential a romantic potential our
philosophical potential our intellectual
potential the things we can do in the
world and for me those have always been
the most important things and I maybe
I'm an acidic with this and
philosophically but I would always
sacrifice enjoyment to be able to do
those things better
I mean this is going to sound silly but
I would eat dog if it were good for
me right I would eat something that was
completely not enjoyable I like that and
maybe I'm just wired differently than
most people but I choose to not use food
as entertainment that single choice
is probably one of the greatest choices
you can make because if you and I've met
a lot of people who who think that way
who think I I want to go out to
restaurants
and and any any food and that's my joy
in life well great but if you run into
problems with that it's it's it's going
to limit you it's definitely uh I think
it's a Faustian bargain but only if
somebody wants to do other things and
and and makes a quality life equation
Solution that's different than that but
it's it's a tricky thing because that's
very limiting yeah because if you use
food as entertainment you will not you
will not like making intentional food
choices you will just want to use sort
of entertainment I think it's I think
it's valid but it's not how I choose to
do it and I think most people are
leaving a lot on the table in terms of
all of the aspects of their life but
that's their choice yeah and I
appreciate how ecumenical respectful
open-minded intolerant your being as you
express this
I'll I'll say something to that effect
um from a personal standpoint um my mom
went for a walk with my wife and I when
she visited us and um she says you all
do this a lot and I says yeah we take a
walk together every day
she said keep doing that baby keep doing
it and I knew where my mom was speaking
from I was she was speaking from the
fact that those days are gone for her
and my dad my dad's still alive I love
him very much and he's still around but
taking walks with my pop that ain't
happening anymore and so even though
it's okay or permissible to Define
quality of life by saying well you know
what my joy is food when we think about
the elements that make that fun it's
things like being able to get in the car
and drive to a restaurant it's like
being able to get out of the car by
yourself on your own strength and walk
to the movie theater where you're gonna
eat that popcorn and drink that soda and
if you take away all those things
because you don't want to let go of the
sodas or the popcorn you eventually lose
those things too and we take for granted
all of the different ways in which
health the ability to move around the
ability to stay awake the ability to
focus your attention on something for
two hours and have an act of mind so you
can discuss it when it's over our health
determines our ability to enjoy those
things too so even if you say I just
like to go to restaurants and eat well
you got to watch what you eat in order
to be able to do that when you're 60 70
and 80. yes people lose that dude when
Josh and I wrote uh minimalism live a
meaningful life and we talk about you
know the different valleys health is
like that's the first thing we talk
about yeah like without your health you
really don't have anything
yeah we don't have much I mean you
remind me of my dad
72 years old he's a physician
and he's he's kind of living in a prison
of his own creation he's kyphotic which
means his spine is curving in his
posture isn't good
he has no glute muscles he he has spinal
stenosis
um he can't do much of anything and he's
probably not going to come to Costa Rica
to see how I live there my mom wants to
come
but he's not going to be able to get on
a plane and come to Costa Rica and see
where I live I don't even know
how much of his grandchildren he'll see
if I have grandchildren in Costa Rica
right so he's he's an illustration and
kind of like maybe your dad a little bit
you know and my dad grew up and and
worked as a physician and and he didn't
prioritize the health he kind of let it
slide and he has his own trauma we
talked about trauma a little earlier I
think he has his own traumas and for him
using food was therapy because it was
the only thing he was allowed to do he's
told me that was fun and so it's put him
in this prison of his own making and
it's not so fun for him anymore in life
it's kind of a bummer because he can't
he can't do much even if I say to him
hey Dad let me fly you to Costa Rica I
want to take you to the beach he
couldn't do it wow yeah did you enjoy
this Standalone patreon highlight if so
you can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free